just when things start to turn around
they fall apart now I know exactly how
FDR felt after Pearl Harbor look you
guys have survived this long please
don't let this ruin your night let's
have fun it's Halloween you love
Halloween
hey I know it would cheer you up let's
go wait outside the bathroom for Tom and
scare him that would cheer me up ready
and God rose Oh Jerry
guys oh good well I think you might be
having a heart attack
what are you serious oh so much stuff is
happening right now call 9-1-1 okay just
breathe okay you're gonna be fine
Noor she's in a dinosaur dysphoric Jerry
get a grip sorry guys apology not
accepted
stop talking [ __ ] I wish I could stop
smelling dude seriously Jerry did you
eat farts for lunch
Tom Jerry's having a heart attack I know
that Jerry okay okay I got you some
magazines and those boring word jumbles
you like to do is there anything else
you need J maybe some gas fix I have
time how is he an give it to me straight
he's great he should be out of here in a
day or two doctor medically speaking how
would you describe what happened to
Jerry he had a mild heart attack yeah
but he also exhibited excessive
flatulence is there a term for having a
heart attack while releasing so much gas
not really gastrointestinal distress is
common during a cardiac event I just
want to hear the doctors say that Jerry
had a fart attack is that too much to
ask so while they repaint the lines in
the parking lot we're asking everyone to
do street parking I'm not street parking
my Mercedes well everyone is I'm doing
it because nobody wants to steal a
Saturn all right
moving on to recycling you okay run just
a little tooth pain I'm fine
continue okay each department will be
getting blue bins do you need to go to
the dentist
Ron I don't like dentists just a second
Hey oh I'm sorry everybody what were we
talking about recycling dentist pulled
the tooth out yesterday but it's always
a good idea to demonstrate to your
co-workers that you are capable of
withstanding a tremendous amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see Tom faint
I'm sorry was your name Jennifer
no it's tenifer with two why's it used
to be Jennifer but then I decided to
rebrand myself oh wait hang on it's an X
o'clock um
well nice to meet you my name is April
and I just wanted to say that your dress
is so cute
it's bungs I saw my spinning instructor
wearing it and I was like shut up where
do I get that oh my god who's your
spinning instructor Gregory or Monona I
go to Yanis who are Gregory and Winona
I've never heard of them before are they
better when Nona rocks my world
seriously you need to get me in there
like that's a must must must she's the
worst person I've ever met I want to
travel the world with her you have to
sorry for the delay ladies I was busy
being ambushed by treachery so did you
have a chance to compare notes on your
respective duties totally tinny and I
have been like totally bonding we've
just been like blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah like talking like so much
forever is also delicious
I know right like the best day ever I
know I'm eating it all up wow it's nice
to see a friendship blossoming instead
of wilting away like a dying turd flower
totes um we also came up with these
nicknames for each other
[ __ ] and skank
how crazy mazing is that last well you
know what I think is crazy
in it for the long haul we are basically
creating a new version of Pawnee and if
Pawnee is gonna commit to one of you you
need to commit to Pawnee tenifer do you
have kids you know I've had
much rejuvenation that I don't think a
baby could get out of there if it tried
you know it can I just say something I'm
having so much fun right now oh my god
me too like so much fun
can I just say something yeah okay you
don't want this job seriously this place
is the pits it's like if you worked here
you'd be like oh and Leslie it would be
like a blah blah blah and he'd be like
uh okay can I say something right now I
totally think that you're right and I
had been thinking about going someplace
warm all my husband is in jail oh my god
can I just say something yes okay you
should totally say in my house in Miami
what I'm serious come by anytime just
let yourself in
the gate kind of jams sometimes but you
can just jump it you are so amazing
right now
you're like skinny mother Theresa it's
Dwayne Wade's house
my guys address off the internet I
really hope he's there when she walks in
and he throws a basketball at her head I
probably should have said no to some of
his ideas but he's on his way here right
now here he is just be cool hey guys
what's up oh I just remembered can I
show you something out to the front area
and leave your cell phones because if no
reason just leave anything they can't
get wet actually like you would normally
okay here we go to the parking lot now
wow this is really sad
yep follow to me guys just go into the
parking lot for normal government
reasons sorry I can't go through with
this I was gonna pull a prank no yeah
I've hired these guys in ski masks to
kidnap us and I was gonna pretend to be
a hero they were gonna shoot me and
drive the van into the river and that's
when the divers would go and pull you
guys out of the water and I would be
standing on the shore like hey get
pranked much what's up
even got these squids from a special
effects guy and I was gonna say this
code word that's what I would push this
button oh my god you've got blood all
over me thank you
I mean it Ben that was amazing really
best prank ever
Lynda cheese 1 seconds open
we've been tailing that kid for a couple
of hours I mean must have been somebody
else
it was poke itis believe me now that
doesn't mean anything to me this is a
peach pit okay
he was eating a peach when I went to go
talk to him this is his ace of spades
this is his calling cards this is what
he leaves all his victims and it's still
warm okay go and arrest him and send
this to the lab we don't have a lab okay
this isn't strictly legal we could talk
to him for maybe an hour and then I
gotta let him go you talked to him first
you have a scary face
hey no in a good way it's scary cute
yeah go talk to him
okay I didn't do this man
I promise now son I'm a police officer
okay you shouldn't lie to me I'm not
I've never been here before and why
would I do this
because you've had run-ins with Miss
Knope in the past second yeah
this isn't one-way glass you know I can
see you you know I like nope I skewered
her cuz she gets all riled up and her
face gets all scrunched up like this
what I like her she's all right you see
what snatch is fine crappy halloweeners
that's hilarious where's the kid in the
conference room trying to hide his
obvious guilt Leslie I don't know what
to tell you I don't know I don't think
he did it
yeah you did and we need a confession
okay Annie and I are going to take a
walk and it's gonna be to see you Vic
itis and these pliers look I'm not gonna
torture this kid nobody said torture why
don't you let me take a run at him boss
in order to think like one of these guys
you have to think like them yeah he's
never seen you before
so imply that you're someone very
important and that you can make his life
hell
greg pikitis would you like some boiling
hot coffee face my name is Bert Macklin
I'm with the FBI
attention please the votes are in and
your Hani hi prom king and queen are
Lucy Taylor and ND Dwyer what
I broke the box and I threw away all the
votes and I voted for you a thousand
times you should get on up there King
Dwyer not without my cool hi Pawnee high
as your prom king I am your ruler salads
my first decree of power is to declare
that the prom queen shall be my wife
April Ludgate who is the best thing
that's ever happened who came to prom
even though she hates it give me this
always next year
no there isn't I'm a senior this is your
wife how old are you he's 33 and I'm 47
slash immortal get out
you